et cette réaction il y a quelques
instants de de l'OTAN un retrait russe
de Carson s'arrête une autre victoire de
l'Ukraine on va retrouver tout de suite
dans la capitale ukrainienne notre
correspondant Gulliver crack bonjour
Gulliver on est le jour d'après et les
Russes ont annoncé tout à l'heure le
début d'un le début de leur repli il est
donc selon déjà effectif quelle est la
situation sur le terrain quels sont en
tout cas vos nouvelles à vous
alors les Ukrainiens accueillent
toujours les annonces faites par les
Russes avec la plus grande prudence mais
la nouvelle aujourd'hui c'est que le
général Valéry zalouchni le chef de
l'état-major ukrainien vient de briser
le silence opérationnel que l'Ukraine
avait mis en place sur ces opérations
dans la région de Herson depuis
plusieurs semaines Valérie zaluzny a
annoncé aujourd'hui que depuis le 1er
octobre l'armée ukrainienne a libéré
1381 km² dans la région derrière sonne
et 41 communes et il a dit que seulement
ces derniers 24 heures il y a eu 12
communes qui ont été libérées et un
total de
260 264
km² et il a aussi précisé que c'était
surtout dans les directions de Petro
pavlica et novorise qui est juste au
nord-est de Herson et puis pile au nord
de Herson en fait commençons dans la
région de nicolaïve une partie de cette
région restée occupée par les Russes
autour de pervomae et en direction de la
ville de Herson même alors là Valère
isalujni annonce effectivement en a
avancé on a repris le contrôle de ces
territoires c'est un début de je pense
reconnaissance que il y a du progrès et
peut-être que la prise derrière son et
pour bientôt mais les Ukrainiens restent
très très circonspectent ils sont allés
jusqu'à qualifier ce retrait russe de
probable mais ils disent encore on ne
peut pas confirmer on n'a pas vu
vraiment ce retrait et comme disait dans
le sujet Nathalie roumanoch la
porte-parole de l'armée ukrainienne dans
le sud ils ont aussi observé beaucoup de
préparation à la défense des différents
territoires dans la région d'aersonne
ces dernières semaines voilà on va
effectivement et on entend la méfiance
exprimée par le camp
ukrainien a commencé par le président
volonymire Zelinski c'est cette réaction
finalement aujourd'hui à Kiev
oui je pense qu'il est trop tôt en tout
cas pour les Ukrainiens pour commencer à
fêter cette victoire et il y a une
grande peur de qu'est-ce que les armées
ukrainiennes vont trouver à personne
notamment en terme de mine et de pièges
quand on parle de piège on peut
considérer la possibilité que des
troupes russes sont là habillés en civil
il faut aussi prendre en considération
les pièges sous forme de mines et autres
appareils explosifs qui sans doute de la
vie généralisée en Ukraine ont été mises
en place par les Russes qui voudraient
infliger des pertes à l'Ukraine même on
se retirant eux-mêmes de cette ville
merci beaucoup Gulliver crack en direct
donc